ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
cucina buttata oggi faremo una roba che
per me è follia pura un esperimento qui
stiamo parlando di rivoluzione stiamo
parlando di innovazione sto parlando di
avanguardia pura ora questa ricetta me
l'ha consigliata massimiliano su
instagram linkando mi un video di custom
food punti o che vi lascio qua sotto in
descrizione per ringraziarli per lo
spunto all'interno del quale uno chef
cucina utilizzando la mia peggior nemica
lei io odio il caffè podio fare la moka
io proprio non sopporto questo strumento
quindi il fatto qui oggi per la prima
volta lo utilizzi e sia entusiasta di
utilizzarlo per me è una scoperta è un
qualcosa di totalmente nuovo un qualcosa
che mai mi sarei aspettato cosa faremo
in questa ricetta creare una zuppetta
utilizzando i vari compartimenti della
moka all'interno di questo inseriremo
tutto quello che ci serve per fare il
brodo all'interno poi del consiglio dove
metti il caffè metteremo tutta una roba
di verdurine e infine qua dentro
metteremo dei gamberi e dei pomodorini
qualora dovesse andare tutto quanto
secondo i piani ci ritroveremo a creare
una zuppetta gourmet di gamberi quindi
metteteci un pollice in su se vi piace
vederci cucinare con strumenti
alternativi perché quella dovesse
piacervi visto che già noi casa
moltissimo lo faremo assolutamente in
futuro detto ciò partiamo subito con gli
ingredienti fori una zuppetta gourmet di
gamberi avremo bisogno di gambe di
gourmet motorini curarne una chip da
urne anche se come come questo prezzo
caro ton kermesse 6 da norme su chignola
urne senza polvere gourmet curcuma araba
gourmet e migliorano fiore picchio
gourmet
come acqua di rubinetto oppure con me e
infine la moka si scivola gourmet a 7 ho
deciso raggiungono con lo spicchio
d'aglio in maniera anarchica eravamo
molte aspettative su questa 0 ma se
funziona o qualcuno mi scrive che gli
stanno venendo a prenderci all'interno
la caffettiera io metterò per la maggior
parte acqua ma vorrei aggiungere poi del
vino per sfumare
non sappiamo di cosa stiamo parlando
ottimo fino al bullone foglioline di
prezzemolo il mio spicchio d'aglio cioè
voglio sbattere detto perché secondo me
fa sapore è importantissimo non lo posso
dimenticare ogni volta a sciacca della
cava il pezzetto dagli 83 ranocchio ripi
picchio della turku mafia per le
proprietà il colore ragazzi lo zenzero
se riuscite a trovare dice anche più
figo in polvere andrà benissimo
aggiungiamo dello zenzero fresco per
concludere un pizzico di sale abbiamo
fatto il sotto prendiamo questo e
seguendolo con la tua camera lo pensiamo
soprattutto a questo punto si passa
ragazzi a questo meritato che dovremmo
fare di verdure naga finissimo io sono
piccolo e meno ci ritroveremo includono
il piatto iniziamo ragazzi i pezzi di
verdura non troppo grandi perché
comunque devono entrare tutti quanti qua
dentro non sono fan dell'anima ragazzi
ma poi veramente piace il caffè come
fate a berlo la poca e inediti così la
moka non ti piace più segoni con quella
moka zucchina fatta la mettiamo da parte
carota cellule eucariote ti giuro che ho
lasciato la torcia dal cappato ur haga
mi raccomando ancora più sottile della
china arca carota invece ci mette gli
anni i ragazzi di più non posso andare
anche perché una pazienza caria fino a
un certo punto aggiungiamo lo conosco un
metodo non far bruciare gli occhi su chi
della cipolla si attaccano alle pareti
liquide che il motivo per cui appena
incontrano a membrana dell'occhio ha
subito fanno piangere se mettiamo un
panno
minato vicino of milano attirati da quel
panno e non vanno a bruciare gli occhi
scott
prendiamo metterlo qui ma dai
basta questo i succhi andranno tutti
quanti a fare del male a lui interessi
calo giochi non fa finta di niente però
non ha certo di il proprio diritto
ho visto di su internet funziona questi
hanno tipo si funziona non ci posso
credere 15 funziona pochi non sento
troppo ma non posso dire che non sento
niente
no no ma funziona funziona da non bagni
con le tue lacrime mi sembrava veramente
la sordità
ma io ci hanno creduto aggiungiamo
ultimissime ingrediente sedano spectra
crack
aggiungiamo tre gambe elite rito in
respira la stronzata del secolo
prendo un 3 gamberini trito e gli
aggiungo all'interno di quella
intermedia perché voglio che ci sia
ancora di più quel sintoni pesce
tagliamo questi gamberi prendiamo il
territorio solo mischiamo perbene
gambero ucima pizzico di sale e
chiudiamo con tantissimo ultimo livello
pomodorini li taglio in uno quarti i
pomodorini sul fondo gamberi e strenesse
all star o svizzero sale e ranocchio rap
e picchio e alla fine coach in in d'olio
dio ci aiuti cbd che ci perdoni judo
tutto a bassissimo calore avevo cucinare
la nostra giu pettinà orme rimarrò così
a fissare tutto quello che succede
sappiatelo sto sentendo delle cose
strane che provengono a cui guarda
bisogna continuare
c'è un problema di base quello è vuoto
solitamente quindi trasborderà il buono
sta continuando a salire fino al 3 ci
siamo ci siamo ci siamo
andiamo a comporre il tutto come se
fossimo shakur me io vado a prenderla
i nostri gamberetti mi raccomando i
pomodorini in giro a metà tra il gourmet
comunque il fatto che voglio magna tondo
carino oggi avevi bruciate
questo è quello che vi rimane dentro
mordor ed è questa roba qui
[Musica]
guarda gli ultimi tocchi e pittore top
più roba b io accetto di olio che mi fa
il puntino di grasso che fatico capito
ho capito
vedi lo vedi la nostra zuppetta gourmet
ai gamberi in caffettiera è finita e
interessante la voglia assaggiare alla
mia ansia adesso è che possa essere
cruda alla verdura ma che non
particolarmente vorrebbero dire a me
piace proprio passaggio delicato
incredibile per quanto riguarda zuppetta
colme di gamberi dentro la caffettiera
promossa ma a pieni voti un'incredibile
processo chimico se lo farete itaca temi
su instagram potete secondo me un po
adattarla quello che vi pare
l'importante è che le verdure siano
super super sottili fatemi sapere qua
sotto come la fareste come la parete con
il nonno per oltre lo lascia tutto
brodino completo ci vediamo giovedì come
video successo la censura caffettiera
finalmente ha un senso per quanto mi
riguarda mi regala una moka mi serve
così